- We have lived for a hundred
years on the assumption of
if it's on film it's true,
and we are about to enter the
era of that not being true.
(soft upbeat music)
(cheering)
You've got your perspective.
(crowd cheering)
I just want to be happy.
Don't you want to be happy?
Hey guys.
Welcome to a very special
episode of the podcast in Cannes.
I'm here with Kevin Allocca.
I'm gonna allow him to kind
of give you the context.
I have a series of questions,
but this kicks off our
interview series at Cannes.
Something that I wanted to
do for a lot of this audience
as the podcast has grown
and become far more 360.
Obviously so much grounded
in entrepreneurship
and startup culture but
over the last half decade
a lot more in the ad world
and the Fortune 500 land.
And what's really excited
about having Kevin on
is I think his organization,
and really ironically what he
actually does for a living,
I think, touches a far majority
of the people listening.
So I'm super excited, bro.
I'm really glad you're here.
Please tell the Vaynernation
who you are and what you do.
- Sure.
So I'm Kevin Allocca.
I'm the Head of Culture
and Trends at YouTube.
I basically work on projects
that help people find
and understand what's popular on YouTube
at the end of the day,
and I've been tracking trends at YouTube
for almost nine years now.
I wrote a book called "Videocracy"
which looks at like ways
that people interact
with culture and interact with video
and how that influences culture.
And so basically I work on,
like on the one side we do a
lot of like consumer stuff,
basically how we surface and understand
what's popular on YouTube,
and then on the other side,
like I am here because a lot of times
people won't understand in this world
what's going on in creativity,
what's going on on YouTube--
- I mean, this world,
this world needs to
pay way more attention.
- Yeah, yeah.
- You agree with that?
- I do, I mean.
We were at this phase a few years ago
where it was like, okay,
there's a lot of audience here,
so, we're gonna pay attention
to that audience but not
take a second to understand
what they're watching or
why they're watching it.
And now we're kind of
entering this other phase
where I think everybody's starting to see,
like to understand how
to reach that audience,
I need to understand why they're there,
what they're doing there,
who they care about.
You know, I'm gonna
give this talk this week
about this in many ways.
But we're so used to making
assumptions and value judgments
about about creativity and about content
and and what people should
like or shouldn't like.
And YouTube subverts.
- It's audacious.
- A lot of that stuff.
You know, so let's take a step back.
What kind of kid were you?
Then where'd you grow up?
Like where you into Star Wars
or like selling Jolly Ranchers?
I see you have two ear ring holes?
- No, no, no, it's just a beauty mark.
I never.
- Oh, those are just?
- Yeah, yeah.
- Those are not?
Those are just birthmarks?
- Yeah, that's right.
- All right, damn it.
I was like why'd you have
two earrings in the same ear?
I was super fired up.
That was like I went to it immediately.
- But I did grow up in like
north of Miami in South Florida.
- Okay, what town?
- Which is interesting place.
Hollywood, Florida.
- Yeah.
That's where all the Russians have gone!
Do you know about this?
Like all my parent's generation Russians
have all moved to this Hollywood, Florida.
It's about to be the
Brighton Beach of Florida.
- I was part of the wave where
everybody's Italian parents
moved to Florida and stuff.
- Makes sense.
- That's how I was born there.
And I grew up there until
I was 18 and I was like,
I gotta get out of here.
- What kind of kid were you?
- I kept trying to figure out what.
In between cultures, in a way.
- How old are you right now?
- I'm 35.
- Keep going.
- So, I was in between cultures in a way
because everybody I grew up with was like
kids of first generation immigrants
from Latin America and things.
But my family was from New York
and they were Italian American.
So, I just was like, I'm
going to be into metal
'cause that's like the last.
- That's what you decided?
- Thing that you should be
into when you're in Miami,
you know, south Florida.
'Cause I just wanted to be--
- You wanna be countercultural
- Yeah, exactly, you know.
- So what did you get into?
- And I was interested--
- Iron Maiden and shit?
- In theater and stuff.
Metallica, Pantera, and I
listen to that stuff now,
I'm like, oh God.
You know?
Metallica, okay.
But some of the other stuff.
- Rat.
- Yeah.
It took me a long time to embrace that
I just really actually loved
what I was around, which was
all the hip-hop scene that
was happening down there.
- Interesting.
- I know.
By the time I went to college--
- Literally, you were that kind of dude,
like you wanted to be counter cultural.
So you didn't wanna be into
hip hop like everybody else.
- Yeah.
- I love that.
Oh I know people like that.
- Everybody's into Wu Tang.
- Steve Unwin.
- I was like, I don't
wanna get into Wu Tang.
But now I'm like, "man,
Wu Tang was so good."
- So good.
- It took me so long
to sort of really appreciate
some of these things.
- So that's when you were into music?
- Yeah.
- What were your other interests?
- I really wanted to work in the movies
for a long long time.
I did theater and speech
and debate and stuff.
Nerd stuff.
- But you were outward?
- Yeah, totally.
- You know, speech and debate,
historically nerd stuff
but it's so crazy now that
everybody wants to be.
Like all these 18 year olds think I'm cool
'cause I give motivational speeches.
And they're all like hitting
me up and they're like,
"I wanna join the debate team."
"I wanna join the speech."
And I'm like, my God.
This was the nerdiest
shit when I was a kid
and now just how the world moves.
- I mean, and one of the
most invaluable things--
- If you think about you right now,
you are like textbook influencer.
Every kid at 14 wants to be an influencer
on Earth.
And literally being into
film, speech, and debate
would be like a real good idea.
- It's so correct.
- You like set the tone
for the framework.
This is actually kind of meta.
This is why I love asking
questions like this.
You're sitting in this
incredibly important
position at YouTube,
which is really outside of Instagram,
the two places where the
manifestation of influencer,
the way every 14 year old thinks.
And literally the framework
of what you grew up
actually is probably the blueprint
a lot of them should be thinking about.
- It's true.
And I did comedy for a bit, too.
And those years that I
spent doing that stuff
like really shaped.
- Comedy for sure
Improv?
- Sketch.
- Yeah, same shit though
at some level.
- Yeah, totally.
But it's all about trying to
understand an audience in a way.
- That's exactly right.
- It took me a long time
to figure out that.
But I was really just obsessed
with why people like stuff
and that is professionally
my job now is like
how do people like stuff?
- Good for you.
How do you end up in this position?
- It's pretty weird.
- You've been at YouTube for nine years?
- Yes.
So, before that I was a
comedy writer for a bit
at the Huffington Post.
And then I worked at Mediabistro.
You remember Mediabistro?
- Yeah, very well, very well.
Yeah, of course.
- So, I was their television
news industry editor for a bit.
Like after Stelter (murmurs) TVNewser
- You worked for Jonah at HuffPo?
- There was this thing
with Barry Diller.
- Paul Berry?
- Paul was there when I was there.
But Barry Diller and Ariana did this thing
called 23/6 which is
like a political satire
thing for two years.
- Yes I remember, I remember.
- And that was my first job in New York.
I was an editorial assistant.
I worked my way up to
associate editor or whatever
during the '08 election run
up and right afterwards.
Like I didn't really appreciate
the economics of it at the time.
So I was baffled when the thing
fell apart two years later.
Now I'm like, "of course".
- That's about to happen in
the world again pretty soon.
Everyone's about to be baffled.
- Yeah.
- "How's my directed
consumer brand not doing well
"even though I'm losing money
on every customer I acquire?"
- I can't imagine how we made it work
for as long as they did.
- Well, Barry has deep pockets.
- I guess that helps.
I knew a lot about pop culture
from working in that job.
- By the way, real quick on that,
just as now selfish for my audience,
back to Barry and his deep pockets.
It's actually not that.
It's actually a lot of what I think about.
I have so many things micro fail
but the macro always works.
You know, if you think about (murmurs)
you think about all that,
they're doing so much that all they need
is three or four wins.
23/6 is right, it's just timing
and the economy and all that
didn't allow them to see it through.
But it's really fascinating
when you look at an icon
like Barry or others,
they're always trying things.
And nobody here knows about 23/6
but everybody knows about
the biggest dating
ecosystem on the internet.
Everybody knows about all the other things
that they've accomplished.
College Humor and all those iconic things.
You know?
- And there were a lot of things
that we were doing back then.
Like these kind of
political supercut things
in that kind of remix style
that YouTube had just launched.
- Were you doing Deepfakes yet?
- No.
- Okay.
- We were several years
away from that treatment.
- D-Rock, when are you
gonna make Deepfakes of me
saying shit like, "I love Tom Brady"?
By the way, for everybody who knows,
that will never happen.
So that will be a Deepfake.
- Just warning everybody now.
- By the way, just like
to be completely scattered
like I like to be.
This Deepfake thing really is fascinating.
- It is.
- Like if you think about
AI's advancement, I'm like wow.
We're talking about a half decade from now
where this shit's gonna be perfect
and now what?
It's so funny,
the openness of the internet
was something I understood.
Like I almost feel like I'm just gonna be
live-streaming at all
times to prove it's me
and what I have to say.
Everybody thinks it's gonna close.
I even just started saying the close-ness.
My counter move to the
close-ness is complete on-ness.
- Yeah.
- If I stream every minute of my life,
there should be no
debate if I ever said it
'cause it's documented if I did or didn't.
I can prove that I didn't.
You've been watching me at all times.
Some "Truman Show" shit.
- D-Rock, you ready to
sleep in the same bed as me?
- I mean, there's so many crazy.
- What's your hot take on that?
- Well, I mean,
we've been aware of it.
- I know you're guessing,
what do you think?
- We've spent this time,
I wanna say we, I mean all of us.
We've all spent this era of
being used to the idea of
if it's on video it happened, right?
And so eye-witness footage.
I mean, that's the thing that scares me.
Especially from international places
where we don't actually
have a window in necessarily
because there's not a free press
and now we're gonna be having
this new dynamic that's coming in.
We're gonna have to evaluate
everything on this new level.
The world is not ready for that yet.
- No, because as you know
that means people are just
gonna go into their prejudices.
By having the ability to say Deepfake,
now you can basically
say that didn't happen.
Like this horrific bullshit
of the police in Phoenix.
If you want to be on the sides of racism,
you can just say that's a bullshit video.
That fucking hurts.
I agree, listen.
- That's the scary part.
- Listen, there's a complete
restructuring of our society
in our faces right now.
Nationalism on the rise.
To your point, that's
a great way to put it.
We have lived for 100
years on the assumption of
if it's on film it's true.
And we're about to enter the
era of that not being true.
- There's another side of this
which is kind of interesting.
- I could be my sister right now.
I'm just cut up imagery right now
and my sister is talking.
My sister Elizabeth is the greatest human.
No, I'm just kidding, go ahead.
- There's another thing that's happening
that's on the other side of this
which is on the much more
kind of creative side
where we're seeing out
of places like Japan
actual creators, on-camera personalities
of virtual YouTubers.
- Oh, I'm aware.
- That are all artificial.
And it's actually allowing
people to do other
more creative stuff.
Allowing them to voice themselves
in ways that they wouldn't.
- There's always good and bad.
- It's an interesting.
- So you we're a writer.
Duh duh duh duh duh duh.
And then what?
A job opened up at
YouTube and you're like,
"I'm interested"?
- Yeah, I was interested
because it was obviously,
at that point it was 2010.
I always loved viral videos
like everybody did at the time.
- Do you remember Narnia
and Magnolia?
- Oh yeah.
- So, I was on YouTube so early.
- Yeah, you were like 2006
or something like that
with the blind?
- February, yes.
I'm so pissed I wasn't
documenting back then.
Yahoo Video and YouTube independent
both flew me out to California.
It was like the first time I ever did.
Even before Facebook
and Twitter I flew out
and they were asking me questions about
why I was making 20 minute videos.
Yeah, you gotta love this.
This is crazy.
I can see D-Rock perking up.
I never talk about this.
I was so early and I
was going so long-form
that besides Rocketboom and Ze Frank
were doing five minute.
And Renetto.
Like some real early people.
First of all, as you know,
no million viewed videos.
None.
Like when Narnia and Magnolia Cupcakes,
like when that exploded on SNL clips
and they were getting like a million,
people were like blown away.
- The Nike touch of gold thing.
- That was just like every video.
When I did Conan in July of 2007,
literally every YouTuber
emailed me and said,
"You're doing this for us."
Besides Perez Hilton, nobody had done
a mainstream media thing.
So when I did that skit in '07,
literally like the 39, the
88 YouTubers that mattered,
that's how many there were,
were like, "hey, go do it for us."
You know?
And so it was super early.
But real quick, they flew me out
and they were asking me questions like,
"why are you making 20 minute videos?"
As in like, "you
shouldn't be making them."
Like only one minute videos work.
- I mean, there's a
long history at YouTube.
I've been there for nine years.
Even the people who work there being like,
"We think this technology is for this."
And then you going and
doing that and being like,
"Oh, actually it could be for that also."
- Well, that's what's fun
about being a platform.
You get to watch.
And that's what you do in the macro.
You know, what's funny?
What you do for a living is
probably, in some weird way,
the thing I enjoy most doing for a living.
Even though I don't do it like officially.
A lot of my comes from
reading and listening
and just reading comments.
How do you think about your
process in figuring out?
You know, inevitably, the
biggest brands in the world,
other organizations that YouTube
wants to do business with
or wants to help,
are asking you questions
like "what is happening?"
"What is popping?"
How do you not make that
just a math equation?
'Cause I know you don't.
- Yeah, I know my boss.
- Otherwise,
anybody could do it.
- She said to me once, and I
think about this all the time.
She's like, "How can
we just take the feeds
"of stuff that you guys look at
"and give them to everybody else
"so they can have the same
insights that you have?"
And I was like, honestly.
- That's not how it works.
- The best insight I have is
this person who is watching stuff all day
and then she and this
other person together
talk about what they've just seen
and they draw some contextual connection
and then we look at the data to verify
whether there's actually
something there or not.
Creativity is really hard
to quantity actually.
- It's impossible.
- Well, of course, yeah.
- That's the point.
- I should say there are
certain aspects of creativity
that you would expect
to be able to quantify.
- Fair enough.
- That are actually not.
And of course, we have
this debate all the time,
like can you actually artificially
create create to create?
Is that even possible and what not?
- You can do a lot of stuff post-game.
That's what people don't understand.
Post-game, we're all heroes.
Everyday we're like,
"Oh, that wasn't good."
'Cause the audience gets a say.
It's the pre-game work.
- Totally, and then you do something
and then someone else does that thing
and like a year later there's a taxonomy
that has been invented.
- 100%.
- That relates to those things.
We've been seeing this in music
for a long time, obviously.
There was no language for
how to talk about punk
when punk was first starting or whatever.
- What do they call it?
- I don't know.
I mean, I'm just (murmurs).
- Got it.
I just didn't know if you knew.
- Even like pop, I was having this debate.
We're having this debate right now,
me and my music trends person,
about whether pop music
has changed completely
or does it even exist anymore?
And the things we think of
as pop aren't as popular
as other things are.
- This is what intellectual
humans waste time on.
- 100%.
It all speaks to this thing,
which is not a waste of time.
If you realize that then
when you look at everything,
you start to say, like I
can't just right now go
and say, "X, Y, and Z is popping,
"so we're going to do another thing.
"We're gonna do this based on that thing."
There's still such a strong element of.
You know, creators all the time,
people that you know, they're like okay.
Everybody's trying to work their game.
Trying to figure out the thing to--
- Titles and thumbnails
and fucking trends.
- Above everything else,
besides all those optimizations,
you have to have such a
strong independent voice
to be able to break through on stuff.
That is so hard to--
- The singular reason I think
that I've had some success
is I'm not good at growth hacking.
- Yeah.
- I mean it.
- So, by assuring that,
you're just focused in on you.
- Yeah, and I don't consume
anybody else's content.
- I'm being dead.
- Nothing.
I watch New York Jets football
and I read comments from
the content I put out.
- So, if it hasn't been
responded to something
that you're already saying?
- I'm insular as fuck.
And somehow I still know what's going on
with Meg the Stallion or like.
- [Kevin] How do you think that is?
- The comments.
- Your commenters are just,
you're gonna hear from
so many different areas.
- And then humans, right?
Meg the Stallion 'cause of my boy.
The human that I have who
has an ear to the screen.
He's curating music for me to listen to.
So, hip-hop I have a human
infrastructure in place
and then I have a funny ear.
And it's always been that way.
Like a lot of the people I
liked before people liked them,
Master P, Bone Thugz.
There's been so many things
that have happened in my career
of just being a consumer,
of being early on people.
So that's that combo.
But a lot of the other
stuff, it's serendipity.
Twitter's very good for me
because it's insular in a different way.
Comments on YouTube and
comments on Instagram
stay within a vortex.
On Twitter, somebody will
reply to me about something
and make a reference to something
and it's right there.
This is like the first time
I've ever articulated this.
I think Twitter helps
me discover some stuff
a little bit more than I realize.
But it's very very insular.
It's funny, I just spoke
to a bunch of the creators
on an off the record convo
where Casey Neistat was interviewing me.
- I spoke at the same thing.
- Great, so you know
who was in there, right?
So the big thing I told them,
that really broke through
and a bunch of them hit me up
who had not known who I was,
especially the younger crew.
I told them, "hey, you're
becoming a fucking creature
"of the fucking algorithm."
I'm like, "You all know the
videos that are gonna work.
"You can bang those out.
"You already know."
I'm like, "You're gonna become unhappy,
"plus you've evolved."
Like when you were 16 to 19,
especially the youngsters, right?
Right now I'm pretty locked in.
Like 35 to 43 is like
there's some edge work.
But fucking 15 to 22,
there's fucking foundational
work of who you're gonna be.
Some of these kids start
off as fucking makeup this
and now they want no makeup.
They think it's clean.
And like I was really pushing them.
And this really resonated.
I'd love to get your thought on this.
This is why I'm setting
it up, it was a question.
I said, "Make a video
that you know won't work.
"That isn't made for the
algorithm and the growth
"but that you just actually wanna make."
And some of them have
and it really did well
and they're really happy.
And I felt like I made a
little bit of a difference
that's starting to be a drum
I'm starting to beat more.
Thoughts?
- Yeah.
Because I think it is
not as formula driven
as people wanna believe it is.
And there's a comfort in
that, I think in a way.
Those people that have success
and rely on those formulas,
there's certain things
about those formulas
that are allowing them to express
certain parts of themselves that
really resonate with people, whatever.
But I actually think
you get to a point where you're like,
"Well, I have to keep doing that thing
"to be able to succeed."
So many people have just broken that rule
over and over again.
- MrBeast is creative above and beyond
just the fact that he's
great at thumbnails.
- 100%.
100%.
And you know, one thing that
you just sort of referenced
in the midst of what
you were saying is that
there is this,
and this is fascinating to me,
if you're 19 right now, you
were 5 when YouTube launched.
You grew up watching you,
people like you, people like--
- Not me 'cause I was selling alcohol.
But yes.
You're right.
- You've got that era of people,
like you grew up watching that.
So like what is what
you make look like when
you grew up watching that?
- Is there a YouTube
hall of fame?
- No, but then how do you decide that?
- Well, the same fucking way all the other
fucking bullshit things do.
The NBA Hall of Fame is a fucking joke.
- Yeah, but I think there's
something that's anti like--
- I'm just basically trying to figure out
which hall of fames I could sneak into.
So, that was that, let's move on.
There's a lot of people
listening right now
who do wanna pop or do wanna get like,
let's be very selfish for my audience.
What are some hot takes, observations,
like diarrhea of the mouth
of things you're seeing
which are completely predicated on
a potential first mover advantage?
'Cause one great thing
I love about my audience
is 'cause I suffocate
the fuck of inaction.
This is not just a place to get motive.
Well, actually it is a
place to get motivated.
By the way, if you're listening
and you haven't done shit
and you just use me
for a quick motivation.
People use motivation as a
make pretend to doing shit.
This is a public service announcement.
Stop fucking listening to
me and fucking do something.
Or continue to listen
to me but do something.
Because D-Rock, you've seen
that whole group of people
who love to Tweet, "Gary,
I stopped watching you."
I favorite them and 90% of them
are just listening now
to a worse version of me
and still not doing shit.
So, give me some hot takes
that might be valuable
for the audience before we bounce.
- First thing off of what
you just said is make stuff.
Because so much of what you see now
feels like it's very packaged
and edited and pristine.
There's a sort of thing
that I gotta start it there
but the lowest stakes
thing that you could do
is just put up something and
see how people react to it.
- All 1,000 episodes of Wine Library TV.
I did no audio, no lighting.
I literally looked like I was a hostage.
If you haven't seen it,
a lot of you don't even
know about my wine videos.
Go to YouTube.
By the way, biggest mistake
of my career happened.
One of the first people on YouTube,
Vidler, a competitive video platform,
gave me 7% of the company.
- [Kevin] Oh my god.
- Think about how hot I
was on YouTube in year one.
They gave me seven fucking
percent of the company
to go exclusively on Vidler.
Plus it worked for me.
I was so long.
What Vidler had was an IP, a patent
on tagging within the screen on the bottom
because people were
complaining in my comments.
I didn't just leave for the money,
'cause I rarely do.
It was,
"Gary, you talk so much in
between reviewing the wines.
"I'm here just for the reviewing wines."
So, what Vidler did was at
the bottom of the player
you could see four little dot.
Exactly, it was fucking amazing.
Anyway, one of the biggest mistakes I made
was leaving the platform.
But like,
if you go to YouTube right now
'cause I think that Vidler is so down
that the videos are gone.
If you go to YouTube right now,
I made sure all the
archives went up there.
They don't have a lot of
views for that reason but
I look like a hostage.
- Yeah but the other
stuff comes as you like.
It turns out that the other things,
the production value and everything,
it like matters but not
as much as like having--
- Tell D-Rock.
D-Rock, that was one of the
biggest things you learned
coming into my world, right?
Admit it.
- [D-Rock] It was.
- Okay, good.
Admit it again for my own happiness.
- [D-Rock] It was the
biggest thing I learned
coming to you.
- What else did you learn,
D-Rock?
- Nothing.
- Good.
All right, production value.
Permit to make, that's a big one for me.
Just fucking make.
Next.
- The other thing is, you know,
you talk about, work around something
that you really actually
are passionate about
and care about a lot.
- Or deeply knowledgeable.
Do you believe?
- Yes, deeply knowledgeable.
But you have to really
care about it because--
- Because if you're deep in
knowledge and you hate it
you'll quit.
- Exactly, it's not a thing
that you can just get in
and be like, "I'm gonna
do this for six months.
"We'll see what happens and then like,
"I'll be a big star after that."
Like, that's not how
that game works at all.
- 99% don't.
- Yeah, you gotta be in it
and you gotta wanna do it all the time.
It's like people ask me all the
time now about writing books
and like, "What do I need
to do to write a book?"
It's like pick something
you wanna be obsessed with
for five years.
Like how hard is that?
- Have you ever read
"Crush It"?
I wanna send it to you.
I'll tell you why.
I think you're gonna shit
that I wrote it in 2008
because it's like so far
completely on your thesis.
Keep going.
- If you just start making stuff
and it's built around
the thing you care about,
you're already like half way to getting
where you need to go.
Then, you gotta pay attention.
It's like all the basic stuff.
The amount of analytics
you have available to you
is incredible.
Most of it doesn't matter,
where you gotta pick the couple of things
that matter to you.
Like what's your retention look like?
What are the thumbnails
that people are clicking on?
You gotta pay attention to those things
because that helps.
That's not just like
optimizing for some thing.
That is just telling you
what people are interested in, right?
- Do you see a lot of people who are
incredible at the thumbnail and title shit
but once the people walk in
the door, the actual content,
because they're not
passionate or talented,
is so garbage that they,
even though they're
good at growth hacking,
also fail?
- Yeah, it happens all the time actually
because the way that just.
- I like that.
- And the way that the
YouTube algorithm is designed
is around retention and watch time, right?
It's about the length of an engagement.
So, if people are coming
and they're bailing,
you're never gonna be able to survive and
it's just getting served up.
- The end, the end.
- It used to work
back in the day.
- Yeah, no, I know.
- There are things that have
changed a lot since then.
- Because YouTube cares
about its end-user.
- Yeah, of course.
It's all about giving people
what they want in a way.
- What's been buzzing in the halls?
Give some shout outs to some people
doing some creative stuff in
the last six months to a year.
What's been a video, a creator?
And listen, obviously this is completely
flavor of the month.
There's gonna be someone
walking by in your hall.
I'm sure everybody that works at YouTube
has their plate of favorites
and different creators.
But like, what's been
in the last month or two
like catching peoples' attention?
- So, and I'm gonna use these
two examples you never hear,
but Emma Chamberlain and Joana Ceddia.
They're both young.
They're both rejecting
a lot of the things.
This goes into what we were
talking about before about
people grew up watching other stuff.
Like these are people who
they don't wear makeup,
they edit like sloppy editing,
but their voices are so authentic and fun.
And I just love the shit out
of everything that they make.
And my team is just like
obsessed with their stuff.
And I think what they're doing is.
- Are they together?
They're doing separate
things but the same shit?
- Yeah, I think they're both in the same--
- They're part of a crew?
- Young people who--
- Do they know each other?
Do they fuck with each other?
They give like dabs?
"Yo, we're different.
"We're not friends but
like I fuck with you."
Like on the same "you see
the world the way I do?"
- Their fans definitely have like.
- But are they like,
let's start this Avenger shit?
- I don't think they're doing
anything together.
Well, Maha, let's get.
- One's from Canada.
- Both of them on the podcast together.
We'll just fuckin'.
- I can hook it up definitely.
- I'm the original fucking
piece of shit editing
fucking voice powerful as fuck.
I'm the fucking grand
daddy of these two ladies.
- You wanna talk about
flavor of the month?
Lil Nas X and Old Town Road.
And he came to the office
and I got to chat with
him for a little bit
about the road.
- Process.
- To getting that thing to where it was.
He's like, it was just so intuitive.
He just like, "Yeah, I made 50 memes
"with the song in the background.
"A bunch of them blew up and
now I have a hit single."
It wasn't like he was
like he just got lucky.
He like knew how to work Twitter.
He knew how to work all these platforms.
People are
asking all the time.
- These people are deeper
strategists.
- They're like,
"is he gonna be a one hit wonder?
"What's gonna happen?"
Well, I don't know.
But he knows how to talk to
people in a way, you know?
- You know he's not going to be.
- [Kevin] That's true.
- Because he's got the tools in his belt.
It's the same reason I will always win.
I'm both the actor and the
producer and the distributor.
- Yeah and when you are the distributor,
the one hit wonder thing.
We've even been debating,
can you be a one hit wonder anymore
when you can build your own
audience to a certain point?
- Right and then what's the
redefinition of that, right?
Is like are we all half hit wonders
'cause it amortizes out.
What else?
- Those two are big.
- Talk to me about something
I'm passionate about.
I'm getting really hot on
the idea of hiring a lot
of 50 to 90 year olds
starting a incubator in a retirement home.
I'm always looking for white spaces.
We're talking about a lot of
inclusion in our society now,
which I'm very happy about.
I think the one group
we're not talking about
is people that are over 60.
- Yeah.
- Like, intuitively I feel like
YouTube's mature enough now.
Is there like some 86 year old crushing
for the other 86 year olds on YouTube?
- We've seen a lot of
older creators now popping.
Interestingly, we're seeing
a lot of it in India,
in other countries, in
Germany I've seen it.
- Yeah, America's fucking
bullshit on this age -sm thing.
- People who are revered
in their community
for their expertise,
like cooking for example.
Why not hear from this 90 year old woman,
how she cooks these recipes?
Like that's exactly who I wanna hear from
when you're cooking something.
- The only people I wanted to
hear from as a kid was the
grandparents of my friends.
Literally history was the
only class I was good at
and I always gravitated
towards the elderly.
- Because they have not grown
up with these technologies.
My grandfather is 101,
he's on the internet every day.
He's emailing me, he's
checking his stocks.
I'll come home and he'll be like,
"Explain to me the cloud."
And it's like oh my God, you know?
But he wants to know, he
wants to know everything.
I think that we have
these kind of beliefs,
these stereotypes that people are like--
- Let's focus on something important.
Tell me everything about your
grandfather's 100th birthday party.
- Oh it was awesome.
It was down in Florida.
At his 95th birthday party, he was like,
"Hey, I don't have any great grandkids.
"That's not cool."
- Oh, so he like took
the mic and was like,
"Fuck you, get to fucking"?
- And all the grandkids were all like.
100th birthday, there's
four great grandkids
sitting at the table.
Everybody's married.
It's a whole other ball game.
Your work, it matters, dude.
- That's cool.
- It was really awesome.
But I mean, he was at the World's Fair
when they debuted the TV.
- What's your favorite
story from your grandpa?
How does your grandpa roll?
Like does he roll the, you
guys are complaining about
fucking the wrong milk in fucking coffee
and we went through
the fucking depression?
Does he roll as like sit down, kid?
Like how does he roll?
- The thing that I've
always been impressed with,
he's a timeless person in a way.
And he fought in World War
II and won a bronze star.
Saw some shit like I imagine.
- Clearly.
- Doesn't talk about it.
He's never like, "Oh man,
I had to fight in a war."
He never says that stuff.
He just wants everybody to succeed
and wants them to be smart.
- What do we end with?
What didn't we cover
here as one final part
for all the aspiration that is listening?
- Your audience is mostly US
or do you have a global?
- No, it's pretty global.
- I think the thing that
is super interesting to me
is how much we're seeing
cross-culture stuff happening.
You both things that are hyper local
and that only make
sense in certain markets
and you have stuff that's playing out
across different markets--
- To that point, I apologize.
Are you paying attention to
what's going on on Netflix,
from where we're starting
to see truly breakout hits?
There's that show "Dark" in Germany
that is like subtitled and
just a global phenomenon
even though it's super
similar to Stranger Things,
which is super cool.
I think what YouTube
and Netflix are showing,
I actually think it's the end of
American pop culture dominance.
I mean, you're already seeing it.
Never in your or my generation
would we see K Pop stars dominate
12 year old blonde girls in Florida.
And so I think it's a
really interesting time.
Is that what you were referring to?
- Yeah, I mean, eight of
the top 10 songs globally
on YouTube last year were in Spanish.
That's like not something
that we would have seen.
And obviously part of that is
Latin America blowing up on usage online.
But I think you're seeing
there's more of an appetite for
perspectives from different
cultures right now
and for creativity coming
from different places.
And I think if you just
are the type of person
who's like me, who wants
to know what's happening
and be like kind of on the (murmurs).
- [Gary] It's the best.
- You gotta be looking
at what's happening--
- No, it's the best.
I mean, Latin trap has been something
I've been watching for like three years
and it's just been super
interesting to watch it explode.
- The global essence of hip
hop is fascinating to me
that hip hop works everywhere.
- Rules the world.
Rest in peace, Nip.
This was great.
- Yeah, thank you so
much for having me by.
- Yeah, thanks.
Have a great week.
We'll see you soon.
- Yeah, man.
- Thanks, brother.
- Thank you.
- Take care.
Keep listening, everyone.
Please leave your comments.
This is a little bit of a new format.
I'd love to get your feedback on that.
Hit me up on Twitter.
All the global listeners,
since we're not American dominated.
I'm just kidding.
I hope you guys enjoy.
We'll see you next time.
Thanks for listening.